hardip Singh naar was shot dead near
this gooda in Su in June the prominent
Canadian activist had called for the
establishment of a separate seik State
called kistan and India had offered a
reward leading to his arrest so when Nar
was killed those here were in no doubt
who was responsible for the last 40
years six have been saying that the
Indian state has been meddling in our
Affairs in Canada here and from day one
when this occurred on June 18th the
whole Community knew that the Indian
state or its agents were involved in the
murder of deep signature and obviously
there's relief that now this has been
acknowledged in the parliament in House
of Commons a police investigation is
ongoing so it's unlikely that any of
what the Canadian Prime Minister called
credible evidence of Indian involvement
will be released to the public but more
and more questions are being asked as to
what exactly Canada is alleging is it a
rogue Indian operative of the Indian
Security Services or is it the security
services as a whole or the Indian
government as a whole that is being
alleged to have killed Nar not too far
far away from here and how strong is
that evidence over the it's been
reported that prime minister Justin
Trudeau made the sudden statement of
parliament because a Canadian newspaper
was about to publish a story revealing
the government suspicions an Indian
opposition leader questioned the wisdom
of the move going public making a
statement in Parliament and so on was
very unfortunate by the Prime Minister
and having gone that far now I think we
have really they have really jeopardized
the state of a very good relationship
and it hasn't gone unnoticed that the UK
and us have not rushed to accuse India
despite their intelligence sharing
arrangements with Canada I hope that we
can make sure that perpetrators are
brought to Justice and that we can all
allow the space for that information and
that investigation to occur before
anybody leaps to judgment Indian
officials meanwhile have dismissed
trude's allegations as absurd and a
ployed to win over the key seek vote at
a time of government unpopularity
shabans Al jazer sorry British
Columbia make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer